When the Flint water crisis
happened in Michigan,
I was already feeling pretty disillusioned
with the state of the world.
I was 27, I had an hour-long
commute to work.
I worked in the recycling
industry, which I liked,
but I spent most of my day crawling
around in garbage cans.
And I would listen to the radio
on my hour-long commute
and hear about how
there were all these bills
that the people of Michigan
wanted to see passed,
yet our legislature
wasn't doing anything about it.
And I found out
that the reason they weren't
was because of a thing
called gerrymandering,
which basically meant that when voting
districts were being drawn,
our politicians would pick and choose
which voters they wanted voting for them
to all but guarantee that they
were going to win the election,
or that their political party
was going to win an election.
I kept thinking like:
How is this the world we live in?
Kids don't have clean water,
politicians aren't doing anything
and aren't afraid of our vote.
Like, doesn't anybody care?
And why doesn't somebody
do something about this?
And I didn't realize
that soon, by accident,
I would figure out that actually
a lot of people do care.
That next morning, before going to work,
just kind of out of frustration,
I made a post on Facebook, and it said:
"Hey, I want to take on
gerrymandering in Michigan.
If you want to help, let me know :)"
And -- the emoji was very key.
And I didn't think that this would
actually do much of anything.
I thought maybe I'd find
a couple other friends
who thought this was a big deal.
Maybe we'd volunteer somewhere.
I certainly didn't think
that it would lead
to a political movement
of over 10,000 people,
that it would lead to amending
our state constitution
or actually restoring faith in democracy
in our state in general.
But when I went to work
and then at lunchtime,
checked social media,
I started to see that people
were responding.
And they were saying things like,
"I've cared about this issue
for such a long time.
I'm so glad you're doing
something about it."
"Please let me know how I can help."
"Katie, let's do this thing."
And that's when it struck me like, oh no.
(Laughter)
These people think I know what I'm doing,
and I did not.
So I quickly Googled:
“How do you end gerrymandering?”
(Laughter)
And it turns out that it's all
related to a process
called the redistricting process.
And if you wanted to end gerrymandering,
you had to get the politicians
to stop being the ones
getting to pick and choose
who their voters were.
And that made a lot of sense,
because when politicians
would draw these lines,
instead of keeping communities together,
we would get districts
that look like this.
In no way does that represent
an actual group of people.
(Laughter)
And why this was particularly
important in Michigan
is we're a pretty purple state.
And what I mean by that
is that about half of us
vote for Democrats
and about half of us vote for Republicans.
And that should mean
that about half of our representatives
should be Democrats
and about half of them
should be Republicans.
But depending on which political
party would be in charge
of that redistricting process,
they would actually have a majority
of the elected representatives,
or sometimes even a super majority,
even though they might have received
less than half of the votes
or exactly half.
And that would then mean
that they don't even have to talk
to anybody on the other side of the aisle,
when passing any kind of laws.
And the other important part
is that redistricting only happens
once every 10 years.
So you have half of the state
being locked entirely out
of the decision-making process
for 10 years at a time.
It did not seem like a good way
to be doing democracy.
So we went to the politicians
and we were like,
"You guys should change that."
And they were like, "No."
(Laughter)
They were not interested
in giving themselves less power.
But thankfully, we figured out
that in Michigan we had
a form of direct democracy,
and it was called
the ballot initiative process.
And so I turned to my coworker Kelly,
we were at our recycling job,
and we started getting
to work to figure out,
OK, what is this ballot
initiative process?
What can this actually do?
And we broke it down
into three different steps.
One, we had to write
constitutional language.
Didn't know how to do that.
Two, we had to gather a lot of signatures
and we didn't know how to do that either.
Three, we had to get about half
of our state to vote "yes"
on wanting to amend the constitution
to end gerrymandering.
And guess what?
We didn't know how to do that either.
But we had this Facebook post
that then we turned into a Facebook group,
and we started seeing all of these people
coming in who were absolutely amazing.
A lot of them were just like me,
they voted consistently,
they cared about the world's problems,
but they weren't really interested
in volunteering for a political campaign
or one party or the other.
But these people are amazing.
I mean, we had veterinarians,
doctors, birthing doulas.
We had butchers and veterans
and even 16-year-old kids
who couldn't vote yet
but wanted to be a part
of creating a change
so that by the time they could vote,
it would actually be legit.
So what we started to do was figure out,
OK, what are all these campaign tasks?
And then what are all
these skills we have?
And how do we start bringing
them together?
For example, we had a woman
who had been in charge
of the Renaissance Festival
for years in Michigan.
And she actually started creating
our first fundraising plan.
And the reason she did that
is because she had experience
raising money for kind of weird stuff.
(Laughter)
And we had another woman
who is absolutely amazing,
her name was Jamie,
she was an engineer and a retired
high school math teacher,
and she was basically the only person
who had actually volunteered
for a political campaign before.
So she had gathered signatures,
she had knocked on doors,
and using her skills
in engineering and math,
she figured out, how could
we take thousands of us
to actually end up reaching
millions of voters.
And that all was really exciting.
And then I had a volunteer, Rebecca,
and she came up to me and she's like,
"I really want to volunteer.
I have time to do it, but I don't think
there's any way I can contribute."
I was like, "Alright,
well, what do you do?"
She was a stay-at-home mom.
And I said, “First of all,
that comes with a lot of skills.
So we've got a lot to work with.
But what are your hobbies?"
She said, "I'm a Jazzercise
instructor and a woodcarver."
Great, great.
We're going to find a place.
So we started thinking,
how could we apply these skills?
Well, it turns out, in order
to gather a bunch of signatures,
you actually need a bunch of clipboards.
And buying clipboards,
even in bulk, is super expensive.
And we started from a Facebook post,
so we did not have a lot of money.
And when we went to our Facebook
group and we said,
"Hey, can you guys help us figure out
what we might be able to do,"
it turns out we not only had one,
but several wood carvers.
And the woodcarvers said,
"Hold on, give us a second."
They went away,
made a plan and came back.
And they had decided to create gift
registries at Home Depots and Lowe's
across the state,
reserving wood so we could cut
our own clipboards.
Then they found warehouses
where we could then cut those clipboards
and start assembling them.
Then they were thinking a lot
about these clipboards,
so they started to think about like,
how do we make them longer
so they can hold both a petition
as well as gathering contact
information from people.
And then they wanted all of us to be able
to be recognized as volunteers.
So they added a nice little red stripe
so that people could know that we're part
of the Ending Gerrymandering campaign.
And they even thought about how
could we turn this clipboard itself,
if we're going to make such
an investment in them,
into an actual tool to educate people
on the process in general.
They ended up being able
to make these clipboards
for only 33 cents each
instead of 11 dollars.
Yes.
And the only reason
we were able to do any of that,
so that everybody could have
a professional tool
that made them feel confident
when talking to strangers about civics,
was because we had
a wood carver as a volunteer.
And that was one of the first moments
when I started to realize
that like, us not "doing politics"
as our day job was actually our strength.
We were looking at democracy
as how we hoped it would be
instead of the brokenness
that it already was.
And so when we were looking at writing
the constitutional language,
we wanted to take
that spirit and apply it.
At the time in Michigan, politicians
were refusing to hold town halls.
They didn't want to meet
with their constituents
because they were getting
a lot of criticism,
because they were writing laws
that nobody wanted.
And so at a time when
we weren't being listened to,
we thought, OK, let's go
listen to each other instead.
So we made a plan to go and ask people
what would they want
in a redistricting process,
what would one that works well
and that we could have trust in
actually look like?
We set a goal of going
to every congressional district,
and we weren't sure if people
were going to show up
because we were brand
new organization, just starting.
But to our surprise,
it was standing room only
at almost every single location.
And we would hear all of these
people saying, you know,
“I have lived in this
community my whole life,
and a politician has never
even visited our city once.
And yet here you are, a random stranger
from across the state,
not only listening to me,
but making sure that my opinion
is going to be used
in a constitutional amendment."
And what my favorite part was,
is you would have people coming in
really skeptical of each other,
never having really had a conversation
with a Democrat or a Republican
or an Independent.
And they would start to talk to each other
and realize that we had
a lot more in common
and all of us just wanted
a political process that worked.
And so instead of focusing
on those differences,
we were able to focus on actual solutions.
So once our beautiful language
written by the people of Michigan
was ready to go,
we then got to gather those 315,654
registered Michigan voter
signatures in 180 days.
But thankfully, we had
that math teacher, so ...
(Laughter)
We figured out that if we could
get about 1,000 of us
to gather about 17 signatures a day,
we'd be able to meet this goal.
But because we had gone around the state
and we had listened to people
about what they wanted,
they all wanted to make sure that this
constitutional amendment passed.
We ended up having over 4,000 people
who were willing to come
and gather signatures.
And they had tons of creativity about how
to talk to people about gerrymandering,
And they were willing to do anything
to gather those signatures.
They went into parades
and even literal cow pastures
in order to make sure
that we were getting the people
of Michigan to sign.
And we ended up blowing
that goal out of the water.
We were able to gather
over 442,000 signatures.
(Cheers and applause)
In only 110 days, may I add.
And although there is no
geographic requirement
of where those signatures came from,
we actually gathered signatures
in each of Michigan's 83 counties,
truly making it for, by
and of the people of Michigan.
So then we just needed people
to vote on the darn thing.
And on November 6, 2018,
2.5 million people,
61 percent of the state,
overwhelmingly voted "yes"
to end gerrymandering
and to enstate an independent
citizen’s redistricting commission.
(Cheers and applause)
Shortly after that, we got to see
did this constitutional law, written
by a bunch of strangers, actually work?
And so our commission
started to come together.
Thirteen strangers were selected.
Four Democrats, four Republicans
and five independent voters.
They couldn't be politicians,
they couldn't be lobbyists,
they just had to be regular people.
Those people were then invited
to represent the state.
So there was a lottery to make sure
that the demographics actually kind of
matched who the people of Michigan were,
making it one of the only
decision-making bodies in Michigan
that actually looks
like the people of Michigan.
They then had the task
of going around the state
and gathering input from people,
asking them what they wanted to see
in the redistricting process.
And they held town halls
that also had standing room only,
even though it was only
very shortly after COVID.
This commission ended up passing maps
that are the most fair maps
that Michigan has ever had.
And in the first election
they were used in, in 2022,
how people voted was an exact match
for how elected
representatives were elected.
This is my personal district
in the "before" and "after" picture.
My favorite part about all of this
is that because we actually
changed the constitution,
it means that in future
redistricting processes,
this is going to have to be
the same process that's used,
which means that future voters
will be guaranteed to have fair elections
from here on out.
I'm sure that each of you guys
have something that keeps you up at night,
that makes you feel like, man,
I really wish somebody
would do something about this.
And maybe you feel
like you aren't qualified
to be the one to do something.
Or maybe you feel like nobody is listening
or cares about this issue.
And I used to feel that way.
One thing that I did not remember
but ended up popping up
on my social media
is I made almost the exact same
Facebook post about a year earlier.
And it said like, “Hey,
let’s end gerrymandering.
Who wants to help?"
And nobody even liked it.
And more importantly,
I also didn't do anything about it.
And I think that's because I felt alone.
I felt like, man,
nobody's even liking this.
Like, I must be the only weirdo
who wants to end gerrymandering.
But by the time I made
that second Facebook post,
what I realized was that actually,
like, a lot of us were feeling
the exact same way.
We were sitting,
feeling like nobody cared.
We really wanted this issue
to be dealt with,
but we felt like there must be
somebody else whose job it is.
There must be an expert out there.
But what I have completely learned
is that you do not have to be an expert
to get involved in democracy.
You don't need a fancy title or a PhD,
you don't even have to ask
permission to try.
You never know where one little
step will end up leading you.
It might change your entire life.
And I think that's really
important to remember.
I mean, there’s a place for experts, too.
I definitely should not perform
open-heart surgery on any of you.
I would not be good at it.
But we are the ones
who are closest to these problems.
Our communities and our kids
are the ones who do not have
clean drinking water.
We have the most incentive
to want to fix these problems,
because we live with its
brokenness every single day.
And we see our communities
as actual communities.
They are our homes.
They aren't red or blue.
They are just us.
So I hope all of you remember
that when it comes to democracy,
all political power
is inherent in the people.
We all are those people,
and this is our power.
I hope you don't forget that.
And you remain unafraid to create
the world you want to live in.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)